disney's encanto is full of hilarious
magical moments from luisa and
isabella's amazing songs to
over-caffeinated kids and a sneaky
shape-shifting cousin yipikai movie
lovers i'm jan and in this video i'm
counting down the top 11 funniest and
most entertaining scenes in encanto
spoilers ahead so take care
of the three main village kids who pop
up in the movie caffeinated kid has the
funniest moments there's his feverish
demand to know all the family's powers
during the opening song tell us what
everyone can do and that's why coffee's
for grownups and what about the way he
still hangs on to his coffee cup even
when he's kicking a football and how he
revvs himself up with caffeine to help
rebuild the casita encanto co-director
jared busch has revealed his official
name is pumped juancho as well as being
adorably amusing the caffeinated kid is
also a nod to the colombian custom of
children drinking coffee
it's so comical during the first song
how mirabelle has to constantly dodge
questions from the kids about her own
gift and when they eventually find out
she doesn't have one she's humorously
brought crashing down back to reality by
a little girl i am just as special as
the rest of my family all right guys
where do i drop the wagon maybe your
gift is being in denial i made a rainbow
camilo's shape-shifting abilities
provide plenty of laughs
including when he pretends to be his
sister camilo stop pretending you're
dolores so you can have seconds
worth of shot
when he makes fun of isabella by turning
into a suitor and when he gets a shock
as bruno and mirabelle race noisily
through the walls of the house and
amusingly when his shape-shifting gets
out of control his head turns into a
very young child who sprouts an enormous
mustache
bruno who's been living alone for years
gets a heartbreakingly humorous moment
with his alter egos when mirabelle asks
him if he's been repairing the cracks in
the house all the patching's done by
hernando who is it i'm hernando and i'm
scared of nothing i said my real gift
was acting
i'm jorge i made
by the way jorge pops up again briefly
during the finale as the madrigals
rebuild their home
and how absolutely adorable is the scene
where shy little antonio gets his powers
communicates with his new animal friends
uh-huh i understand you rides through
his rainforest room on the back of a
jaguar bounces about on a hammock and
swings by on a snake and frankly let's
face it more movies would definitely
benefit from adding capybaras there's
some wonderful little details in this
scene too if you look carefully you can
see dolores put her hands over her ears
as the crowd's cheers become too much
for her super hearing
and what about the hilarious way that
the perfectly poised golden child
isabella swings onto the scene as the
family prepares for antonio's gift
ceremony did someone say
flowers
[Music]
thank you please don't clap
thank you oh it's nothing
i love everything about this moment from
the way the murky scene changes to
golden light as isabella works her magic
to the priceless look on mirabelle's
face as she watches her effortlessly
graceful sister swing by adored by
everyone there to the serious rapunzel
vibes i get from isabella's magical
swinging vines and to cap it all
isabella literally throws her gift in
mirabelle's face the incredibly catchy
chatcha style of we don't talk about
bruno is an ingenious way to show
everything mirabelle's estranged uncles
blamed for in the family i love peppa
and felix's dance routine as they
explain how bruno got inside her head
causing her to create a hurricane on
their wedding day and the way bruno's
painted as a villain with camilo
shape-shifting and singing about rats on
his back is darkly humorous then there's
the townsfolk blaming him for their woes
which shows how everyone uses him as a
scapegoat for totally ordinary things
that can happen to anyone and if you
watch carefully there's a fantastic
detail in the background which some of
our eagle-eyed viewers spotted as a
hooded bruno bops along to the music
behind dolores and mirabelle
as the song ends dolores reveals she
overheard bruno's vision of the magic
dying and the house breaking apart which
then leads into the hilariously
memorable dinner scene with isabella's
suit mariano but just before we get to
that i want to thank our video sponsor
hellofresh who make getting a tasty
home-cooked meal on your table a lot
easier hellofresh delivers a box full of
exactly the right ingredients and
recipes you need for a week's worth of
delicious healthy meals saving you a ton
of time on grocery shopping and prep
plus getting the precise amount you need
for each meal reduces food waste every
week there's a stack of options to
choose from including family friendly
calorie smart pescetarian and veggie as
well as quick and easy recipes that take
as little as 20 to 30 minutes to make a
couple of meals i've made so far from my
first box are this delicious spicy
mushroom mapo tofu with spinach and
jasmine rice and sea bass fish and chips
with tasty lemon zest garlic mayo and
mixed leaf salad and you can make eating
healthy and fresh an easy new goal for
2022 with our amazing offer of up to 16
meals completely free plus three special
gifts when you sign up for a new meal
kit at hellofresh.com and use the code
flick16 hellofresh gets produced from
farm to your doorstep in under a week
for peak freshness and for my next meal
i can't wait to try out this turmeric
roasted cauliflower lentil and coconut
doll so go to hellofresh.com and use
code flix16 for up to 16 free meals and
three surprise gifts the proposal dinner
with mariano and isabella is an absolute
comedic gem as every thread in the story
collides to spectacular effect mirabelle
watches in agony as dolores begins to
reveal the secret about bruno's vision
and the reactions of each family member
as the story passes along the line
builds both the laughs and the sense of
impending doom and her antics as she
attempts to cover up the house literally
splitting apart you're doing great draw
looks that could kill from isabella as
if that wasn't enough one of antonio's
commodities steals a piece of bruno's
vision and luisa breaks down as she
struggles to move the piano
chaos descends and dolores blurts out
peanut butter fish and she's in and
she's gonna destroy the magic and now
we're all done the house cracks and one
of isabella's flowers sprouts out of the
floor and sucker-punches mariano in the
face foreshadowing her reveal later that
she doesn't really want to marry him and
to top it all off the town's people pop
up with their laughably well-timed
congratulations
[Applause]
bruno's rat pack lead mirabelle to find
where her uncle's been hiding all these
years we get some disgustingly funny
moments thanks to his little rodent
friends who use his hairbrush and his
toothbrushes to clean themselves run the
old-fashioned record player using it
like an exercise wheel fight over food
scraps in his trousers and provide free
entertainment what do you like sports
this scene is a sneaky reference to
colombia's historic match against west
germany in the 1990 world cup and
there's even a nod to el cole colombia's
most colorful best-known football fan
and the telenovela plot about a
forbidden love involving an aunt their
love could never be it's a shout out to
gabrielle garcia marcus's novel 100
years of solitude which heavily
influenced encanto hat tip to everyone
in my video comments who spotted these
the rats also revealed bruno's
whereabouts to dolores rats talking in
the walls and to antonio the rats told
me everything
don't eat those
and the little rodents put in another
appearance at the end of the movie as
the family's photographers
mirabelle's horrified reaction when she
finds out that to save the miracle she
has to make peace with isabella is just
perfect
look at how reluctant mirabelle is and
how she tries to get it over with as
quickly as possible so we should just
hug let's hug it out compared to a
sister who drags it out gloatingly
demanding an apology for the ruined
dinner with mariano go on
apologize mirabelle just can't go
through with it though and hear
accusations you selfish entitled
princess finally get isabella to reveal
her true feelings i chuckled as she
makes flowers sprout up into mirabelle's
face as her anger at having to be
constantly perfect erupts as for her
song there's definite shades of elsa's
let it go song about it which is funny
given the elsa-like poses in these
flower statues one of which isabella
goes on to decapitate the multi-coloured
world izabella creates for herself
embracing vibrant and sharply
contrasting colours is just gorgeous and
a world away from her previous pastel
colours there's even a nice edge to her
song where she grows some carnivorous
plants and it's impossible not to laugh
when issa makes another flower pop up
out of nowhere to bop mariano in the
nose again
luisa's burnout anthem surface pressure
is an insanely catchy cleverly
thought-out piece of storytelling by lim
manuel miranda about the burden of
impossible expectations and the whole
sequence is beautifully animated with
loads of entertaining moments and
ingenious hidden details from the
titanic style ship with the madrigal
name on the side heading for an iceberg
to luisa shooting into the sky in a
superhero pose to mirabelle desperately
holding on to a seemingly storm-tossed
ship but when the camera pulls back we
see she's actually riding the waves of
luisa's bulging bicep and then there's
the donkeys everywhere they're luisa's
backing dancers and get some fun busby
berkeley style shots during the song
that the band playing on the madrigal
ship that the audience in the battle
with cerberus they weigh down luisa's
scales and they're decked out like
unicorns with pink eyeshadow to match
the candy-coloured clouds as louisa
rides them through the sky in a rare
moment of joy then there's this moment
where they slow-mo fall through the air
which i just love and one's even there
at the end of the movie with a tray of
drinks to help lisa finally relax and if
you want to discover even more brilliant
details and disney easter eggs hidden in
encanto tap here to watch my things you
missed video there's also a link in the
video description so what are your
favorite moments in encanto let me know
in the comments below and if you enjoyed
this then do like and share this video i
really appreciate it you can also tap
left to learn all about the incredible
deleted scenes and characters cut from
the final movie such as isabella's
magical potato people thanks for
watching and see you next time yupikai
movie lovers
you